sur le campus de schoelcher une
structure qui hébergeait 740 étudiants
avant confinement contre une bonne
centaine aujourd'hui nous avait un
premier bâtiment ici océane où nous
avons le de loger principalement les
étudiants étrangers
en face vous avez la tour et l'extension
palatin et matt eliane et on a un
bâtiment à l'entrée de l'université qui
s'appelle l' annexe et tous ces
bâtiments là ce sont des étudiants
martiniquais guadeloupéens ou de
métropole la vie sur le campus en
période de confinement demande une
attention particulière pour la sécurité
des résidents l'administration a dû
faire appel à des étudiants relais pour
garder le contact avec la communauté
ils ont créé chacun groupe whatsapp tous
les jours à une heure donnée les
étudiants disent ok je vais bien ceux
qui n'ont pas envoyé le message
steve et francesca les appels et s'ils
n'ont pas répondu au téléphone
quelqu'un de l'administration se déplace
avec les clés pour ouvrir voir si
l'étudiant va bien steve est le de ces
deux étudiants relais il nous indique ce
qui préoccupe le plus la communauté
savoir quand est-ce que ça va être lavé
le confinement mais sans le monde et on
est logé à la même enseigne donc on
attend mais c'est la question qui
revient le plus souvent
alors le confinement période
particulière pour les résidents pas
grave on fait avec
ça change pas de grand chose il ya
toujours les vigiles il ya toujours les
personnes qui s'occupent de l'entretien
etc
c'est juste qu'on est tous elles
retrouveront steve depuis sa chambre qui
entre contact avec les autres étudiants
méditation yoga et sport s'impose une
discipline de fer pour ses cours en
tissage demi de mon travail scolaire
ainsi va la vie sur le cloud de chêne
cher une vie rythmée par les courses
parfois les coupures d'eau le sport le
soir sur le site
et puis le chat du campus fatigue web
exfiltré vers le lamentait au début du
confinement
deux jours après il était de retour pour
tenir compagnie à tout le monde